light of Christ and the power spirit to
be with us all good afternoon and
welcome to the United to the remans
reunion a hugs are not the united church
of santa fe how do you be welcome there
too but to the celebration of eight
decades of women why des honoring the
past challenge in the future we're very
glad you're here please be seated as we
begin our time together just a few
announcements before we head into the
program number one thank you all very
much for being here today this is the
kickoff event for the women's reunion
and in conjunction with the other
reunions and also convocation a number
of people have made this day and the
next couple of days possible you'll find
their names listed in the wonderful
booklet that Connie moisture and others
helped put together on behalf of the
whole school we and all the alums we
thank all of you staff and alumni alight
who have made this day a possibility
just some housekeeping kinds of things
one is that you'll notice that on
Wednesday there are breakout groups for
various kinds of interests and caucuses
there's information about those groups
in the end the bulletin and also the
signup sheet for those groups are in the
car the sign-up sheets are in the
commuter lounge so take a look at what
you might be interested in having
conversation with over lunch on
wednesday and sign up on the on the
stunt up sheets in the commuter commuter
lounge also in that same area if you
have handouts that you want to
distribute to people for convocation
please you can put them on a table in
that in the lounge as well also in the
canoe in the common room you will notice
two big oars whiteboards at the top of
one is the question what do you give
thanks for for your time at Yale
Divinity School we invite you to take
time and write out what it is that
brings you back to this place what it is
that fed you while you were here what it
is that has inspired you in your
ministry wherever and however that
ministry has taken place it's a
wonderful way of gathering the thanks of
our time together
the second board asks for who's in your
great cloud of witnesses that community
of saints who believed in you to get you
here who believed in you to get you
through here and who have believed in
you ever since then so that you might be
the person of God doing the things of
God that God has called you to do so
take time during the various times that
we that you're not going to be in a
lecturer or doing other things to think
about what do you thankful for and who's
in your great cloud of witnesses and
that leads me then to the next part as
speaking of great clouds of witnesses as
we assemble here in this time I'd like
on behalf of the whole school and all
the alums to thank our speakers for
today Margaret Farley Emily towns and
Joan fortune forsberg they're all three
known to many of us and their BIOS are
found in the in the bullet in their
booklet as well and we simply rather
than taking their precious time now to
to go into those details I invite you to
take time not while they're speaking to
take the booklet and find out what
they're about and what they all they
have done these are three women who have
truly inspired generations upon
generations of both women and men here
at Yale Divinity School and one person
who is also continued continues to
inspire both ongoing students alums and
this nation and this world as a whole is
Dean Harry Attridge Dean of the L
Divinity School he needs no introduction
and he's going to offer us not only all
the all the support that he's been
offering for this big celebration over
the last year but also to give us a
presentation on yts women by the numbers
Harry it's good to have
thank you very much I'll keep my remarks
pretty brief and I'll keep the numbers
relatively small because i'll be doing
numbers throughout the course of the
week i think it is important to in this
community of memory and hope to
celebrate the memory of the women who
played such your important leadership
roles in our lives and in the lives of
the churches that we serve and to think
about the ways in which that leadership
is going to be continued going forward
you have a number of numbers in your
booklet that will talk about ever so
briefly and let me just begin by noting
them that note the female enrollment
column do you see that starts with 0
this is well I have it here you see it
all right there it is its pages 2 & 3 it
starts with 0 and continues with 0 much
like the mile in monument downtown have
you been down to see that the women's
table in front of sterling Memorial
Library goes all the way up until
nineteen twenty when we finally get some
women at the Yale Divinity School
although they weren't enrolled in degree
programs there were nonetheless five
women in each of the classes of 20 and
21 and 7 and 22 who were taking courses
of study here finally in 1932 women
started to be enrolled in the ale
Divinity School there were four in that
year the first of them graduated in 1935
gradually the numbers pick up as you can
see they get all the way up to the 40s
maybe even 50 by the late 60s and early
70s mmm if you look at the chart at the
bottom of the next page you can see that
there's a kind of predictability about
these numbers they're roughly about ten
percent of the population of students
that was here a totally accidental I'm
sure in any case whatever accidents had
kept the numbers at that percentage
changed in the early 70s and you can see
that from 1974 on women started coming
in a much larger proportion of the
student body so that today we are almost
at parity one year about two years ago
we were exactly 5050 with 201 men and
201 women
in the student body students on the
faculty have also increased over the
last several years and I was delighted
this last year to have all of the senior
appointments that we made one hundred
percent of the senior appointments that
we made consists of senior women
Jennifer hurt who's with us here today
kathe Tanner who's coming in systematic
theology and Mary Michelle both of them
unfortunately one loose fellowships for
this year and so are on leave during
their first year but they will be with
us next year and some of them I think
will be around a little later on this
week women count some thirty percent of
our senior faculty at this point and
probably about fifty percent of they
overall faculty numbers depending on how
you count them in any case we have a
substantial cadre of women faculty
members here to balance the women who
are in training for leadership among the
student body so as this community of
memory and hope I think we can remember
and celebrate the women who've been with
us in the past the Pioneers the first
women to graduate from Yale Divinity
School Thelma Allen and Bernice Beulah
in 1935 the first woman ordained in the
Episcopal Church who was a Berkeley
class of 38 graduate Clara Loveland the
women alums who've been a part of our
life here at Yale Divinity School Joan
forsberg who i believe is with us today
and serene Jones will be with us later
on this week and Carolyn sharp who is
still with us from the classes of 53 85
and 94 and some of the other women alums
and such as Shannon Clarkson who's also
here with us today who contributes to
our educational program we have women to
celebrate in the leadership of church
and world that women like Alana Myers
the first president of the Pacific
school of religion and the first general
minister and president of the disciples
of Christ sherron watkins class of
eighty-four and we have the large group
of women who are going to be leading us
into the future Margaret Farley who was
with us today though emeritus she is
still active with us and engaged in many
significant ways Emily towns the
associate dean of Yale Divinity School
Nora tubs Tisdale and preaching kathe
Tanner and Jennifer hurt and Mary
michela I've already mentioned as well
as
rollin sharp Adela Collins in New
Testament Sally promi in American an
artistic history and Teresa burger in
liturgical studies all senior faculty
leading the charge as we go forward
we've come a long way since nineteen
thirty-five we have a ways to go there
are some of our denominations where
women are not is fully accepted as they
are in others and I hope that in the
course of my lifetime or certainly the
lifetime of our students that will
change as it has changed over the past
80 years in other denominations so
welcome to the celebration and let's at
this time commit ourselves to going
forward seriously to make our hopes and
dreams a reality welcome one and all
Thank You Dean Attridge not only for
those words but also for the incredible
support you've given both men and women
as they come through this school and now
my brothers and sisters as we enter into
the time of reflection and sharing and
hearing about the past but also
challenging the future I invited to come
together by taking into our lives God's
gifts and being together in a time of
prayer as we begin our time together let
us breathe in deeply the gift of God's
peace let us breathe in deeply the gift
of God's hope for us and for all
creation
and let us breathe in God's gift of deep
abiding love for us and for this world
you hear the source of all of these
gifts you or as close as the next beat
of our heart the next breath we take we
give you thanks for all the ways you
have made known to us your peace your
hope and your love through our time as
students and in the years that followed
we give you thanks for the journeys that
have brought us back to this place and
we give you thanks for this time to
gather to remember and to feel at home
once again from the journeys to share
our stories but most of all to be
renewed by this place by one another and
by your deep abiding presence and lively
challenging spirit in each of our lives
and all of our lives all this we ask in
your name Amen and now it's my great
delight to introduce to you Margaret
Farley who has taught at Yale Divinity
School for three decades for a
presentation on home from the journey
remembering and gathering
you can't imagine how it feels we're
everywhere I look I recognize you
generation upon generation truly the
title given to this opening session of
the 2010 why do yes women's reunion is
in some ways puzzling or perhaps better
challenging and I trust that the
organizers of this session who gave it
this title thought of it primarily as
challenging Yale Divinity School was a
home for us at one time in our lives and
of course it is now for those who still
abide and work and form community here
but how is it home for all of us today
that's the puzzling part and especially
a home to which we come during and after
our journeyings no doubt our memories of
ideas have made their home in us and
they will be awakened precisely because
we have returned for a short time our
past has its meaning in our present and
our present will find its ultimate
meeting in our future personal
experience of time is not like ordinary
understandings of space that is one part
outside the other human time accumulates
within us becomes a part of us like the
rings of a tree or the notes in the hole
of a melody as past flows into the
present it is not an inert appendage as
present becomes future both past and
present are somehow transformed in their
meaning for better or for worse for
those of you who are alums weather for a
long time
or short so much has happened since you
lived and worked and formed community
here your personal and ministerial lives
have stretched out in time changing you
and the world around you you are all
called equally in the spirit of god when
you came here to prepare for divers
ministries in the churches in your
families in other professions in
whatever contexts you chose or found
yourself but you went forth to sometimes
vastly unequal situations where your
credentials were accepted or dismissed
exalted or trivialized depending
sometimes only on your gender or your
race or your theological perspective or
on whether or not you were ordained or
whether your call beyond yts was
recognized as sufficiently traditional
or whether you were able to find
communities of faith and committed love
your professional and ministerial and
personal lives have stretched out with
beginnings and endings still to be
enacted but the between of the
beginnings and endings will in a sense
matter most of all and the between will
be different for each of you you're
between partakes of both past and
present which is why we have to reflect
on both even as it is the bridge to a
not yet future my own experience with
women at y dias began in 1971 a long
time ago
yet a relatively short past immediately
prior to this in 1970 a wide es alumni
committee on the ministry of women
chaired by joanne forsberg issued a
report describing the history and
current situation of women as women at
wide yes it contains statements like
this little has been done to diminish
the jaundiced attitudes toward women
seminarians and their vocational
aspirations which remain among their
male peers less has been done to foster
an atmosphere of support among women and
in the community nothing has been done
to prepare women to cope with the
discrimination they continue to
encounter in the churches and their
ministries difficulties in placement
lower salary scales for the same work
lower status at a time I'm still quoting
from this report 1970 at a time in which
our society is being confronted by a
second wave of protest against the
continued economic social and vocational
discrimination against women the
seminaries have tended not to be in the
vanguard of the church but have trailed
miserably behind the concern leadership
in denominations on the National Council
of Churches the report proposed among
other things that a position be
established for a vocational religious
counselor for students that some women
be appointed to the full-time faculty
there were none in 1970 that active
steps be taken to address gender
discrimination in the school that more
women be recruited
the BD program what most of you know as
the m.div program and encouraged to seek
ordination and that courses should be
offered at yd s dealing with the image
rule and relation of women and men in
the church family and society this
report obviously gave a rather grim
picture of the experience of women at
yts until that time although these women
also had richly positive experiences
times when their hearts no doubt were
burning as they studied the ways of
faith and the possibilities for action
the 1970 report became part of the
radical change that began to take place
in 1971 the beginning of a surge that
continues still today its concerns were
energized by the social and cultural
situation of the 60s and the women who
flocked to IDs and other seminaries
after that were filled with a power for
change the present is markedly different
from the past in the world the churches
and wide es there are not the same
problems or at least not in the same
degree that were identified in a 1970
report although there are always new
challenges for example as Letty Russell
and I talked through many years our
course in feminist theology and ethics
it became apparent to us in our lighter
years that questions had changed
resources had multiplied feminist
thinking had diversified but also the
knowledge of feminist theological and
ethical classics had been lost
the work of women like Mary Daly
Elizabeth schuessler firenza rosemary
ruther Beverly Harrison and many many
others new students by and large in 2007
when we last taught the course did not
know any of these writings and hence
they had they had lived the fruit of
them one might say enhance their
understanding of women's critique
retrieval and reconstruction of major
doctrines in particular was truncated so
the last time Lettie and I taught the
course as I said in 2007 not long ago we
decided to include the classics as well
as major new writings by women this was
an eye-opener for many of the students
both women and men and a source of new
energy for probing the depths of what
they believed no one lives in an
historical vacuum in each of your
generation the past has moved to the
present remaining within each life even
as it is transformed and every one of
you that has passed through this
divinity school has changed it however
imperceptibly you became a part of
someone else's life and you change the
institution as well there are some
dramatic examples of this such as the
massive effort to save the quad some of
you will remember the habitat for
divinity event
the countless meetings the
communications with alumni the partial
victory of remaining on the hill and the
fuller victory of saving all the
buildings women and men students and
faculty and alums were part of this
effort although it must be said that
women were its backbone and its force of
communal grace what followed was also
dramatic that is the remarkable
renovation of the school some of you
seeing it for the first time I know and
the school's movement into the 21st
century for example in terms of
classroom design and all that became
possible because of this you see around
you the change in places and forms of
worship both preservation and
transformation not achieved without
struggle but now in car nating the
commitments and hopes of a divinity
school whose tradition is a living
tradition and has always been sold and
women have been a sterling part of what
makes the tradition live other dramatic
examples include the simple explosion in
the number of women's students to the
point where it stabilized as Harriet
rich just said at about half the student
body and the not so simple but
nonetheless remarkable growth in members
in numbers of women faculty
administrators and staff there are also
less dramatic but equally significant
examples the profound conversations held
within the walls of this school changing
forever the lives of individuals and
even of the school the new forms of
partnership with the rest of the
university the diversity achieved slowly
and still slow
developing within the student body and
the faculty the openings to acumatica
land interfaith dialogue and on and on
some things some of you may find
yourself regretting but there can be no
doubt that this school is vibrant in it
struggles its achievements its ongoing
life the fabric of the between
constituted by these efforts shaping the
present and future has notable threads
running through it for example in the
continuing commitment of the school to
prepare persons for the churches as well
as society think two of the path forged
by particular individuals whose marks
have been irrevocably woven into the
life of the school administrators like
Joan forsberg who is wisdom and comfort
saved the vocations of countless
students
and whose quiet presence and courageous
action made so much progress possible
and faculty like Letty Russell whose
challenges to injustice showed so many
new ways to mend creation and who's
creative pedagogy and theology startled
and nurtured new insights and new
convictions in the hearts and minds of
so many who encountered her and worked
however you have experienced your past
and your between since graduation from
why Diaz we are all challenged by a
present social and cultural situation
marked by such things as escalating
technological progress yet disaster we
only need to keep in mind the human
caused eruption of untamed oil in the
mexican gulf wars and rumors of wars
circled the globe not only in
afghanistan but on the continents of
Africa Asia and Latin America the stark
contrast of poverty and wealth haunts
our own country and the whole world as
natural disasters but also human
engineered economic meltdowns leave far
too many people homeless jobless
vulnerable to the worst as well as the
best of human responses of violence or
compassion a new mean-spiritedness and
vitriolic self-righteousness have come
to mark the political landscape here and
elsewhere and the churches are all too
often torn apart especially over ethical
issues and especially issues of gender
and sexual identity but of course also
remarkable humanitarian efforts are
mounted in the present situation
movements to care for earth are growing
and countless individuals and
organizations stand in active solidarity
with the marginalized progress has been
made whether in the treatment of
terrible diseases or in the fragile
peace achieved in a few places around
the world yet optimism is not our
general move
we recognize that today's signs of the
times still call us to struggles against
so much hatred and fighting and still
against racism and sexism and they call
us to engage in struggles for economic
and political liberation respect for
genuine pluralism and renewed efforts to
bring about justice in our generation on
our watch for our neighbors near and far
this common present is the context for
our faith and our action our Labor's in
the church or in society but what can be
said now about the heart of your
vocations in whatever forms they have
taken the patterns and places of your
lives have been diverse some have found
a home in their professions and
ministries and families some have lived
homeless in a sense even if they are
ordained first called to one path then
to another many of you have learned that
this worldly meaning of we have here no
lasting home no matter what you have
been on journeys since your first call
to come to ideas and the journeys
themselves may be where you make your
home whether you have found your place
or you are still searching for it you
may have come to know the kind of love
that asks you in a myriad of ways to lay
down your life for others thus coming
paradoxically to find yourself if so you
have probably also learned
that every great love is tried by fire
but not destroyed with other women who
challenged a view of Christianity that
glorified suffering you may have learned
that the point of the cross is not
finally suffering and death but that
relationships can hold I speak in
Christian terms here and of Christian
symbols but i trust that some analogies
may be found in symbols of other
traditions in which some of you may
stand in the cross of jesus christ the
divine human relationship is forever
restored and it holds and our
relationships with one another can hold
never letting go our sense of dignity
truth justice and call we can glimpse
the possibilities of a love stronger
than death a love that can withstand
complexity limitation distance even
failure to sustain such loves the
between of our lives gets woven with
insight into experiences of the already
not yet experienced is not of
disillusionment or mere resignation but
of an upsurge of hope this is at the
heart of our movement into the future
and at the heart of our call but to
return to our title for this opening
session home from the journey gathering
and remembering what can it really mean
surely we who have traveled forth and
now come together again
our only fleetingly here at home we may
still be without a home of a certain
kind or we may have many homes yet here
no lasting home our ministries in
whatever form they take perhaps always
include the ministry of easing the
burden of persons driven from home so
many millions in our world today living
endlessly in a strange land or never
being welcomed to a table perhaps in our
journeys we have heard the call to put
our roots down not simply in a place but
in the hearts of those we love and we
have thereby learned to welcome one
another into our own hearts as we
reflect in these short days about our
individual as well as our shared pasts
we shall no doubt recognize things lost
and things gained but we shall also
remember and perhaps relive those in
encounters those events of which we can
still say we're not our hearts burning
within us and we may see a new our call
to make our home in one another's hearts
and ultimately in the heart of God if so
we can go forth but in a sense never
leaving we can return but in a sense
never having been away welcome home
now we have other voices to hear we have
with us here an embarrassment of riches
Joan forsberg and Emily towns and Joan
is going to briefly reflect with us with
us on her experience which for many of
us is now past but whatever she wants to
say about it so many memories in this
room it's overwhelming for me I don't
know if you have the same feeling I do
when you look out the window at that
tree and how many how many years how
many days in Chapel have we related to
the glory of that tree and so many
connections as I look around the room
Thank You Margaret I have two
incarnations at this institution the
first I arrived here in 1950 as a
student who was here from 52 53 and some
of my cohorts and some just ahead of me
are are here our hearts were burning
when we came to this place burning with
an eagerness about learning and about
serving and we were a very serious crowd
and my recollection in the early 50s and
we had to be because i will tell you
truly early in the first week Dean pope
and love Dean pope and he came down to
talk to the new women students all ten
of us who had been admitted for that
year according to the quota system and
he came to meet with the ten of us and
welcome us at 301 where we lived several
blocks away at the corner of edwards and
prospect where the women lived and he
welcomed us and then he told us that it
was that was very serious business to be
here because they had kept out so many
men to let these girls in
this world all ten girls and that we
should be and the it was very important
that we finished the course because we'd
kept out all those men and so we should
be very serious about that and finish
our three-year program and then he added
and I've never sorted this out totally
he was a wonderful Southern Christian
gentleman and I loved him dearly he said
it was very hard to decide among all the
women who had applied and so we very
carefully went over your applications
and we looked very carefully at all your
pictures and we picked the ten women we
figured would stay the course
well you know
you see it takes a while for him to rest
and it took a while for us to register
and I don't remember that we reacted
particularly I mean we were this is 1950
we were very nice girls who had been
well brought up to be happy with the
system and you didn't get angry at a
nice professor in front of you even
though you weren't quite sure what he
meant by that govern anyway um it was a
wonderful time here the Golden Age of
faculty as they frequently say it was
the doctor bein neighbor Calhoun Napier
the Pope two popes anyway it was a
wonderful wonderful faculty and we loved
it and we thrived under them and but
there were no women faculty I'm not sure
whether we ever verbally regretted that
out loud or even noticed it you know at
that point that wasn't in the
consciousness there was no technical
women center the 301 prospect street
down there at the corner Edwards in
profit all the women lived there 28 or
30 of us so forgiving the three-year
program and so it was a women center of
a kind and there was lots of support
there but not I don't remember any
conversations about consciousness
raising or about roles of women or about
identity or about what's wrong with the
school that it doesn't have more
equipment in there I don't remember any
of that we were serious students who
were thankful to be here and we pretty
much pretty much thrived on there was
political consciousness raising though I
remember that they said tell some
anecdotes I remember this one the day I
arrived at 301 was bringing my suitcases
in the front door up the steps and at
the top on the second floor I heard one
voice saying energetically to somebody
else obviously a first-year woman's
student that's the other woman was
saying to her but you can't be a
Republican and be a Christian
and there I was a nice little Republican
from the little white suburban town in
New Jersey I thought oh my there was
also a an organization a group of
students and one faculty or two who did
what was called religion at the news
desk and then Austin was part of that
and others who dealt with all the news
and political news in the world so there
was consciousness about that and there
was some diversity among women students
in my class of 10 there was one woman
from Puerto Rico and one of Japanese
background from Hawaii and in the rest
there were some women of color and the
rest of the among the rest of the women
who were there in our Bernice cozy
pulley and and all in those early years
so we weren't all we didn't all look
alike which was great um ok now I'm
going to jump from the early 50s to the
70s I have two minutes footsteps I'm
sorry the main thing you need to know
about the early 70s was the massive sea
change in this school it was not just
that that of the first woman faculty
came but also the first Roman Catholic
faculty Margaret Farley and renowned
also Berkeley divinity school joined us
so for the first time it was a
university Divinity School and a church
related seminary connected and then
there was suddenly an advocate for women
and nobody quite knew what that was
about except the women started to apply
those were the years when the Holy
Spirit blew the doors open of every
seminary in this country and the women
who had been waiting came pouring in
everywhere church-related seminaries and
other schools across the country in 71
72 73 74 there were 28 women in the
student body when I started as well it
was called advocate for women I quickly
said could we call that advocate for
students so they don't think women are
needy and helpless and whatever I so it
came advocate for students there were 28
the next year there were 52 the next
year there were 90 women
the next rig went over a hundred and I
stopped hatching all the simplifications
the men faculty said what are you doing
you out r you were not allowed to
recruit there was no recruiting at Yale
and nearly up to the early seventies
newton and so you can't be recruiting i
said i'm not recruiting the holy space
blowing them through the door and I just
I just welcomed them I'm gonna stop
there and we get to back to some other
things now be plenty of time also to
share more but now we turn to Emily
towns who is one of the newer members of
the faculty and also the academic dean I
want to start by thanking both Margaret
and Joan it's um I wouldn't be here if
you hadn't been so
and i also want to put faces to i'm
going to do this in stages so don't jump
up before I call you put faces to the
women full-time women faculty who were
here and some of you I've seen and i'm
not sure i've identified everyone but if
we could start with jennifer just stand
and say your name so folks can see you
anyone else in this session section over
in here keep standing keep standing more
back this way I know Nora tubs Tisdale
was here but she may have left Yolanda
okay and adjunct faculty women faculty
Shannon other folks anyone else up okay
and i'm not sure if any of our visiting
women faculty are here today I just
think it's important to see the faces
Martha you I think it's important to see
the faces you hear the names often but
some of you may not always see the faces
and know them so I just wanted to see
everyone to see who I work with along
with the men but also
I'm going to do some little bit from
some of the things that Margaret's
address touched off with me and I'm
going to start with something some of
you have heard me do before but most of
you have not and it's a soliloquy from
the movie daughters of the dust by Julie
dash it's the story of a Gullah Sea
Island family it's Gulliver on this
island on the islands off of South
Carolina and they have lived on these
islands basically untouched in this
movie it was made or set in the early
late 1800s Early 1900s and this family
is going to move to the mainland and up
to New York and so there's a little bit
of consternation going on with what's
going to happen and there is one seen
near the end of the movie in which EULA
who is one of the granddaughters of Nana
pisat has been raped and the audience
knows that the person who everybody
knows who raped her was a white man
she's with child and no one knows whose
child it is is it her husband's child
Eli or is it the the child of the result
of this rape the narrator of the story
is the child who's not yet born and the
child is their child july and EULA's
child well there's another woman who
comes home to the island yellow Mary who
was a prostitute and she turned to that
life after she had been raped but her
husband left her so she had no other
resources on the mainland so she turns
to prostitution and the women are
ostracizing her and EULA says this to
them there's going to be all kinds of
words in life to take let's not be
afraid to take them we
serve them because we're all good women
do you do you know who you are and what
you've become you're the daughters of
those old dusty Tings Nana carries in
her tin can we carry too many scars from
the past our scars own us a mother's
scars our sister skies our daughters Gus
thick hard ugly scars so no one can ever
pass through to hurt us again let's live
our lives outside of the folds of those
old wounds now when I started it was 77
it wasn't here it was in another school
West
in the city of Chicago and it was very
clear we had inherited some fairly thick
scars that we didn't even know what
those scars were all about we just knew
that they were present and so we began
to think through as students how do we
do that how do we deal with something
that we can't yet quite name but we know
is present and we can see the women in
front of us responding to this and
trying to not make their struggle hours
but be true to the struggles that we saw
in ourselves so one of the things that I
think that Margaret challenges us to do
is how do you pass on the need to
remember that there is a struggle to not
make the struggles that have come in the
past the ones that this generation is
dealing with let them have their own
scars and wounds and work but to talk
together so I first think we have to
recognize that there is one and second
we must have deep intergenerational
conversations and I want to stress
conversations because so often those of
us who are old I'd like to tell those of
us who are younger what they should be
doing and they listen about as well as
we did so we should probably learn a
little bit from our own hardheadedness
that the way to help people understand
more is by conversations not telling
third these conversations have to move
from just being talked to analysis and
strategy sessions and then finally we've
got to act now many women come knowing
the classics of contemporary voices here
at Yale
a cup of classics and the contemporary
voices and I am happy to say some days
that it's a joyful moment when one or
two or several come into my office or
catch me in the hallway or find me in
the common room or see me in the servery
or catch me after chapel hill when they
know I might be particularly vulnerable
and say I'm taking this class and I want
to know why there are no women in it
that we have to read I think that is a
mark of movement and it's not just women
who come and ask that question it's men
as well we have moved a good bit so what
I think we are about now is helping them
go deeper if they come knowing this from
their undergraduate careers or where
they've been before then the job of Yale
is to help them go deeper so we must be
a faculty who can help those do so with
precision and rigor in other words to be
wide es at its best it's scholarly and
ministerial best we need to be about
helping women develop a belief in the
gifts God has placed in them with
humility but without apology and I think
that's the harder thing to pull off too
many of us come in here being humble not
enough without apology so we're not only
dancing Sarah's circle I know Margaret
you're standing so I'm almost done we're
not only dance sarah circles now a wide
yes we're also learning how to do a
shake dance for the postmodern age that
needs more heart and soul in a world
that gets more sterile and indifferent
each year so as one of the old black
women of my grandmother's generation
used to say to her friends
girl it's time to get a moving and so we
are
and now I turn it back over to tullys
Margaret Joan and Emily I cannot thank
you enough both personally and on behalf
of all who are gathered here for the
wisdom that you've offered us in a very
succinct kind of way the things you've
reminded us that we know and the things
that you have challenged us to relearn
once again in this time we'd like to
offer some time for you to for us
together as a community to reflect on
what we've heard and also on some of the
questions that have been raised Margaret
raised in her presentation the question
about how is this home or where have we
found home both here but also in the
ministries and lives to which God has
called us and for which God has
empowered us what have been challenges
what have been the graces you'll see
both in the booklet but also on your
yellow yellow program on the flip side
of it are three questions in your life
in your life at yts and beyond what
would you identify is the greatest
challenge you faced what would you
identify is the greatest race you've
known and where have you found a home in
ministry in God's heart in both I'm
brought you to take just a few moments
to reflect on these questions it's not
too much time is not enough but
certainly enough time to go really deep
but to begin to think about this is
these questions shaping our time
together and here at the Women's reunion
and then as the spirit moves you turn to
someone next to you and just partner up
for just a few minutes and share an
answer to one of those questions about
grace about challenge about finding home
these questions are mainly to help help
us think about the time that we have and
also the time that God will call us to
when we leave from this place yet once
again to face the challenges of our
lives and ministries and also to find
the Grace and the home that God offers
us wherever we are so take a moment
especially for the introverts to be
introverted and think about think about
sure what you might do with these
questions and then turn to someone near
you someone suggested everybody turn to
their right but if we do that then that
doesn't actually work so figure out how
you're going to turn to somebody next to
you and find someone to share this with
preferably somebody across the
generation perhaps we'll come back
together with the singing of you be
kotti toss but take some time now